hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm a [ __ ]
toski I think it's a stand-up comic
funny man up and for a lot of [ __ ]
people in his life
Keanu Keanu um
starring Kegel he Kegel exercises time
keegan-michael key Jordan Peele from key
and Peele they are probably my favorite
sketch comedy being around right now
like you know they're just a duo I'm
sure they have a team of writers but
they're dare I say not sense in living
color has there been a show this good
key and Peele to me is the best sketch
show and they doin two dudes not a like
a huge cast like SNL and they'll even do
some stuff they did that one on the
slave trade and I'm just like whoa you
don't know and I'm like it so it's like
really edgy and then they can defuse it
really well with how funny the sketches
I'm just like I'm blown away by their
sketches have I mean I've been inspired
by their sketches so much where it
starts off one way and the escalation of
how things go and sometimes it takes
such a random turn but it works then
they commit to it oh yeah I think
they're [ __ ] brilliant man especially
Keegan I just I remember watching him
I'm at chibi and I'm like that guy is
going to be like he needs to be big
because he always delivered and that
show was kind of like Mac Mac whatever
Keegan was on I was like man this guy
has got some severe talent and like what
have you not seen him in a movie and not
completely annihilate history he's great
always destroyed when he's like in a
supporting role I noticed or like guest
starring he doesn't try to steal the
show yeah yeah he won't overpower yeah
he just he wins the akut man yeah he
doesn't try to like outshine anyone yeah
man the blacks know how to do the comedy
sketch is really well the black started
damn okay yeah thanks quote me on that
it's the blacks no I didn't sound racist
if I'm complimenting as a bald white man
I can't say any no you can't symbols it
I'm half white but no one can tell
hey how are you how you doing nothing
makes sense are you okay
Maisie broke up
well it's gonna be okay direct clearance
I want you to meet kion
there's anyone shaggy come by here
there's 17 Street flips the seven
centuries lips will get where are they
17th Street please take a white whites
with what you can't talk like that here
man we really are in trouble because you
sound like Jean Ritter all the time no
big difference
straight to the
in the market right now for like a
gangster pet so
bricky you just feel solution why are
you talking to me like that I talk like
that sometimes dry this weekend has been
we want to never get pulled over again
you drop a custom it you were spared
Nvidia core ain't no died
[ __ ] right here oh wow
wait who are the right of main writers
of this Alex Ruebens he's Alex Ruebens
Wow dude I gotta say man I'll say it as
I go Anaheim BB that was so unexpected
it like that's the last thing you'd
expect like you feel style too like oh
go like a let's just do it just for a
left fielded Devon do a story Noah okay
so he's ready knock key and Peele as
[ __ ] ton since 2012 okay yeah he's done
he's done like more than 60 episodes
okay so oh yeah dude this is like can we
see this like everyone's like you wait
for that one there's always like one
massive comedy in a decade right like
when Dumb and Dumber hit the out of year
old virgin right this is the one I hope
so I mean it's cute like so your faith
is in Keane field one have they ever
ever let us down that is true and it's
very true I have 100% faith in this
movie man I do too I had a big smile on
my face that was so funny I just the
concept of like even just reading the
description I am TV friends hatch a plot
to retrieve a stolen cat by posing as
drug dealers for a street how do you
even know this the plot is funny the
plot the concept is funny it's like a
sketch idea yeah I'm watching the
trailer I'm like I could see how they
made this into a full-length movie cuz a
lot of the time and you watch like
people from sketch
you know especially from a sketch comedy
show going to a movie it the movie just
feels like one long drawn out sketch I'm
not getting the vibe from this it's it's
like a sketch idea but I could see how
they're turning it into like an 80 to 90
minute comedy if it's that length and
they're pulling in so many different
elements from so many different genres
to write look like the action seems like
yeah cool in it and stuff you know so it
looks like a really well put like a
super well put together film in like
that's exciting man and if it's from the
guys who've done leo from campy oh this
is from the guys who do can't peel can't
go wrong if they're fun guys it's it's
the the writers for key & peele good
news big they know how to surprise they
know how to take left-field turns I feel
like this is gonna be a hybrid of what
we want from a key & Peele movie
combined with elements of surprising us
I feel like they all know how to do that
like if there's any cuz their sketches
are like little movies oh yeah a lot of
the time they're like little films
they're short they're like sketch short
films they're not just sketch they've
also been known like like be edgy so it
seems to me like like Dumb and Dumber
was like a really slapstick douche
comedy and I think it has that element
in it those guys know how to push lines
a little bit so it's gonna have that
element in it and then you see it kind
of goes that if this whole movie kind of
slips in and out of reality yeah where
it's like you seem to be in reality then
there's a gangster holding your cat
that's all bugged out and it just boom
you're completely in fantasy like that
those type of movies I especially in
comedy genres like I'd completely love
that kind of stuff you know I just it
adds it it's like it layers it you know
there's so much about the film that I'm
[ __ ] looking forward to like so much
about this movie Will Forte with the
with the controls yeah Will Forte has
such a unique style of comedy I'm
excited for to see what he does with
that with that part cuz he's so strange
and kind of off a little bit you know
you know what they're great at doing
with their sketches providing you with
characters even if you only get like
three minutes to meet this character
they still have a defined character
that's what looks cool about this it
does it doesn't look like it's just
about silly gags and jokes these are two
characters I could be on board with yeah
you don't like the appropriate
african-american
and who has to pose as tough black guy
hey it's it's a funny it's a funny idea
and like that bit of the n-word i I've
heard so many things that like the
n-word bits before but that was like a
really well done bit yeah
right for the introduction yeah I just
like like the timing is just like you
know jokes all about timing
yeah the preciseness of it it just looks
like they spent a lot of time capturing
this thing perfectly I like I'm gonna go
out on a limb and say this is like a 10
for 10 but I hope so and this is key and
Peele
I feel like key and Peele well it's cool
it's like we know they're like best
friends yes so you're getting a buddy
comedy with key and Peele but you're
giving them an environment to have a
hybrid of to throw in slapstick and
routine because it's such a ridiculous
plot and it's so not what you'd think
when you hear can you peel are finally
making their movie and I love that I
love how they make it about this
gangster movie that's about their kid
for their first movie not to like
they're not conforming any
conventionality like they're they're
still just doing their own thing you
know that's what people gravitate to you
know like you get like like sometimes
overly studio to comedies and you just
know they're just same jokes same little
situations and throw you know put them
through this but that's just it just
gets sour so quick this is the stuff
that's like you know yeah they're the
people it's like like if anybody like
airplane introducing airplane yeah
groundbreaking mmm you know I think this
is one of those movies to that that just
does something completely unique and
different yeah I hope they don't I hope
they don't ever end their show know what
I think it's it's I think they already
said this is a find you not hear that
yeah I didn't mean to bring with that I
belong that's I broke that news I'm
sorry
cuz right what is this look so [ __ ]
good moment and then I just dropped that
bomb shatter in my heart right here the
movie we're gonna have to go back to I
lost a testicle when you said that I
didn't see anything fall out of your
pants
Ian let me teach you something about
leadership for a second here okay please
give me the lesson I've been there's a
rule of communication and timing when to
present him for me
and at the time that you presented the
information to me of said key and peele
show ending you have failed on your end
to be a leader and me be your follower
because what you do is hurt not empower
so we're supposed to empower you would
have been better off keeping your
[ __ ] mouth and power guide okay art
of communication presentation I'm just
no just don't interrupt ever well I go
Arnold trump shine I'm definitely gonna
go see a kiosk he on it oh what a title
Jerry say there's maybe like once every
four or five years I'll go to see a
movie twice in a theater I am putting my
money down I am double down the line
well we're now in this video I'm gonna
watch the trailer again like it looks so
funny yes if you needed the channel
please subscribe to the real rejects
once you subscribe you become a reject
yourself eating at aus ki stand-up comic
and sketch writer and has his own
channel start a little thing on their
web series or the show called Satan's
corner baby's corner stop by so yeah
follow me on vine and Instagram I use
those a lot please please follow me on
vine and Instagram I need more followers
because dammit I am NOT getting the
product placement I deserve and he needs
more I need more product placement from
the bottom of your hearts I met someone
with like a hundred thousand less subs
than me
okay like $1 for like a 30-second spot
I'm not getting this now I might not be
a girl who can like do bikini photos and
get such huge product placement you know
but Instagram if I can build that up
they'll probably offer me better deals
on YouTube hence better promotion better
product placement cuz I know the way to
earn respect from people on YouTube from
audience is to plug products
top to bottom